[Applaudissements]
jama
ces moments fixe avec
vous l'aviez vous la maman est ce que
vous connaissez cette personne fils
c'est une autre affiche on voit que
c'est bon il s'appelle comment julien
comment julien c'est quand j'ai un
prénom connaissez pas son prénom et il
est beau tout ça va mon soutien et il
est magnifique julien on aimerait avoir
un micro un pour les alors peut-être que
tu vas aller dîner avec ton père ce soir
attention a cédé à faire rentrer
maintenant
ne laissons pas une personne de
l'entourage de capucine à naves
alors là ce n'est pas nicolas ça c'est
dommage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors je crois que vous êtes la fille de
capucine nadal la droite s'est passée ta
meilleure amie
oui voilà sefyu d'armes oui ça va fiona
ça va et je vois qu'elle a déjà fait koh
lanta la collier d'immunité
merci fiona attention
thierry on a un proche tu vas rentrer
pour thierry mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans le meilleur ami thierry
moreau on voit les idées noires
différents son meilleur ami le capitaine
stéphane merci ces unités pas ses deux
salles d'eau gens met en scène stéphane
vous êtes très beau en tout cas ça va je
peux toucher votre banque
merci j'aime bien et les bossus cire
perdue elle et jean-luc on va faire
rentrer je crois quelqu'un qui vous est
très proche
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est qu'ils ont laissé monfils